IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
ONE THAT ENSHRINES HIS "AMERICA
RONALD REAGAN BUILDING IN
WASHINGTON, THE PRESIDENT
OUTLINED A PLAN THAT INCLUDES
SECURING OUR BORDERS.
CHILDREN AND OUR GRANDCHILDREN.
WATCH.
>> ON TOP OF EVERYTHING ELSE,
OUR LEADERS DRIFTED FROM
AMERICAN PRINCIPLES.
BELIEF IN AMERICAN GREATNESS.
ON JANUARY 20, 2017, I STOOD ON
THE STEPS OF THE CAPITAL.
TO HERALD THE DAY THE PEOPLE
BECAME THE RULERS OF THEIR
NATION AGAIN.
AMERICAN SUCCESS IS NOT A
WON.
TOGETHER WE WILL LEAVE OUR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN A
NATION THAT IS STRONGER, BETTER,
FREER, PROUDER AND YES, IN
AMERICA THAT IS GREATER THAN
CALL ON YOU.
DANA.
>> Dana: AND NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGY IS CONGRESSIONALLY
THREE YEARS EVEN BEFORE THEY DO
SOMETHING.
I THINK ANY PRESIDENT THAT PUTS
OUT A PLAN, THAT'S THE PLAN
UNTIL BREAKING NEWS CHANGES
EVERYTHING.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
POP UP IN THE WORLD.
THERE'S TWO THINGS I REALLY
LIKED ABOUT IT.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A PUSH ABOUT
THIS NEXT YEAR AND WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT MORE, MILITARY
PLANES AND NEW PLANES NEEDED
ALSO THE CYBERSECURITY ISSUES WE
ARE DEALING WITH.
THE PRESIDENT TOUCHED ON THAT A
LITTLE AND I THINK WE'LL SEE A
PUSH IN THE NEAR, ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO FUNDING.
THE OTHER THING I LIKE HEARING
THEM SAY WAS AS A FORCE FOR
GOOD, MIRACLE WE USE INFLUENCE
TO ADVANCE OUR INTERESTS AND
BENEFIT HUMANITY.
I THINK THAT KEEPS US SEPARATE
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES.
WE ARE EXCEPTIONAL FOR A REASON
AND THAT REALLY IS THE MAIN
REASON.
>> Kimberly: YOU LIKED IT.
DEFINITELY SEEMS YOU THOUGHT
ABOUT AMERICAN EXCEPTIONALISM.
I GET IT.
ECONOMICALLY, IT MEANS YOU HAVE
MORE MONEY IN THE WORLD HAD MORE
INFLUENCE AND MORE MONEY TO PAY
FOR LITERARY REDNESS.
IF YOU ARE READING IT, YOU WOULD
SAY ANY PRESIDENT OVER THE PAST
200 YEARS COULD HAVE HAD SIMILAR
THINGS.
WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT IT, YOU
THE LIST OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS HE
THINKS HE'S HAD AND THEN HE GOT
TO THE STRATEGIES.
IT FIT TOGETHER FOR ME THE
THINGS THAT STOOD OUT WAS
MILITARY READINESS WHICH WE HAVE
A HUGE PROBLEM WITH AND THE
SECOND PIECE SAYING WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A FORCE FOR GOOD
IN THE WORLD.
>> Greg: I HEARD KIND OF THE
SAME THINGS.
I AM ALWAYS TIRED OF HEARING,
IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT THE CHILDREN.
BUT I'M OKAY WITH THAT.
THIS IS A CENTRAL PIECE OF HIS
AGENDA.
I CALLED IT THE STOOL OF
SECURITY.
IT'S A TABLE WITH THREE LEGS.
DEALING WITH OUR ENEMIES AND
ADVERSARIES LIKE ISIS NORTH
ADVERSARIES LIKE ISIS NORTH    A
ADVERSARIES LIKE ISIS NORTH    D
NORTH KOREA.
TO THE ABOVE.
THE BORDER BECOMES MORE VALUABLE
IN TERMS OF NATIONAL SECURITY
WHEN YOU HAVE TERRORISM.
THOSE ARE THE THREE LEGS ON THE
STOOL.
THIS POINT, SOMEWHERE ALONG THE
LINE, WHAT IS GOVERNMENT FOR?
THIS.
WITHOUT THIS, THE STOOL OF
SECURITY, YOU DON'T HAVE FREEDOM
PROSPERITY.
THE LAST THING POLITICALLY IS
THAT IF YOU DON'T LIKE TRUMP OR
YOU JUST COULDN'T GET --
COULDN'T ACCEPT HIM, THIS IS A
KIND OF AGENDA THAT MAKES YOU
OVERLOOK THE SMALL STUFF THAT
SOMEBODY IS RIGHT ON THE BIG
PICTURE, YOU CAN FORGIVE OR
OVERLOOK THE SMALLER, MORE
IS THIS UNDERLYING CHAOS AND
CONFLICT.
SOMEBODY IS RIGHT ON THE BIG
PICTURE, IT DOESN'T MATTER.
WHEN WE LOOK BACK, WE WILL
REALIZE IT DIDN'T MATTER.
NO ONE WILL REMEMBER A LOT OF
THIS STUFF.
WE WILL REMEMBER THE STRONG
MILITARY AND ENHANCED SECURITY
BORDER PROTECTION ARE KEY
COMPONENTS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
NEW NATIONAL SECURITY STRATEGY.
>> LEADERS IN WASHINGTON IMPOSED
NEVER APPROVED.
A POLICY WHERE THE WRONG PEOPLE
WHO ARE ALLOWED IN OUR COUNTRY
ON THE RIGHT PEOPLE ARE
BEEN LEFT TO BEAR THE COST AND
A NATION.
>> Kimberly: JESSE, YOUR
REACTION.
>> Jesse: I THINK HE WAS
TRYING TO STRIKE A VERY CLEAN
BREAK FROM PAST ADMINISTRATIONS
BY SAYING HE'S HERE TO IGNITE A
REAWAKENING IN AMERICAN
CONFIDENCE AND USHER IN A
AMERICA FIRST AND PUTTING THE
PEOPLE ABOVE THE POWERFUL.
AMERICAN GREATNESS HAS TO BE
GUARDED VIGILANTLY BECAUSE OUR
DESTINY IS NOT ASSURED AND HE
TRIED TO INSPIRE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO BE COMPETITIVE IN A
SEE IS WHAT WE HAVE.
AND THEN HE POINTED TO THE
LITANY OF FAILURES FROM PAST
ADMINISTRATIONS.
TAXPAYERS BAILING OUT OTHER
ALLIANCES.
JOBS BEING FLEECED BY OVERSEAS
WARS WHERE WE TIED.
HE WENT ALONG THAT LIST BUT THEN
LIKE GREG SAID, POINTED OUT THE
FOUR PILLARS.
PROTECT THE HOMELAND.
YOU JUST HEARD HIM.
REINFORCING THE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS IN GETTING RID OF THINGS
LIKE CHAIN MIGRATION IN THE VISA
LOTTERY.
ALSO DEFEATING ISIS AND MAKING
THAT'S THROUGH CUTTING TAXES AND
REGULATIONS.
AN OUTSTANDING BAD TRADE DEALS
WHERE WORKERS GET HOSED AND BIG
COMPANIES MAKE OUT GREAT.
PRESERVING PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH, HUGE REINVESTMENT IN
THE MILITARY AND FOCUSING ON
MODERN THREATS LIKE
MISSILE-DEFENSE AND CYBER.
IN THE END, A KIND OF TWEAKED
PRESIDENT OBAMA, TRYING TO FOCUS
IMPOSE OUR WAY OF LIFE ON OTHER
PEOPLE AND WE ARE NOT GOING TO
>> Kimberly: LOVES BEING
NUMBER ONE.
JUAN, DID YOU HEAR THIS THROUGH
THE SAME PRISM?
>> Juan: NOT AT ALL.
I AGREE THAT HE WAS PLAYING
AGAINST GRIEVANCE POLITICS,
GOING AT THE PRESIDENTS WHO CAME
BEFORE WHEN I COME I THINK
SOMEBODY ELSE, MAYBE YOU, DANA,
SAID IT COULD BE ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS BASICALLY KEEPING WITH
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY FRAMEWORK.
WHERE IT DIFFERS, AND TO ME HE
IDENTIFIED IT.
YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE HIM CREDIT
FOR THAT, CHINA AND RUSSIA ARE
EXERTING INCREASING EVIDENCE
THAT THEY WANT TO INCREASE THEIR
PROFILE IN THE WORLD GLOBALLY.
TO ME, IF YOU LOOK AT ASIA,
WHERE WE BACKED OUT OF THE ASIAN
TRADE DEAL, I SEE CHINA STEPPING
UP IN TERMS OF ECONOMICS AND
GIVEN WHAT HAPPENED IN SYRIA BUT
ALSO WITH IRAN.
YOU SEE RUSSIA PLAYING A BIGGER
ROLE.
TRUMP IDENTIFIES THAT BUT THEN
DOESN'T SAY EXACTLY HOW WE WILL
RESPOND.
TO THE CONTRARY, HE SAYS WE'RE
GOING TO BE MORE FOCUSED ON OUR
INTERESTS AND OUR SECURITY.
WHILE, OF COURSE, WE ARE GOING
TO FOCUS ON OUR SECURITY BUT I
DON'T SAY THAT WE ARE TAKING THE
GROWING INFLUENCE IN THE WORLD.
I WAS OUT AT THAT REAGAN LIBRARY
THE OTHER DAY FOR THE NATIONAL
DEFENSE FORUM, AND THIS IS WHAT
THE DEFENSE EXPERTS ARE SAYING.
THERE'S A LOT OF TALK FROM
TRUMP, A LOT OF RHETORIC, BUT NO
GOING TO BE.
>> Greg: HE IS REPRIORITIZING.
THE NUMBER ONE THREAT ISN'T
RUSSIA, IT ISN'T CHINA.
THE OTHER THINGS ARE BEHIND THE
BALL AND HE WILL DEAL WITH THEM
AND MAYBE THEY CAN HELP.
MAYBE RUSSIA CAN HELP.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT FROM THAT
ANGLE, THAT'S HAPPENS.
>> Juan: I DON'T AGREE AND BY
THE WAY, THERE WAS AN
INTERESTING PHONE CALL OVER THE
ATTACKS THAT WOULD'VE TAKEN
PLACE IN ST. PETERSBURG.
I DON'T THINK TERROR IS THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE.
IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
NATIONAL SECURITY STRUCTURE, I
THINK YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT TERROR WOULD BE
GENERATED IN A PLACE LIKE THE
MIDDLE EAST.
ESPECIALLY AFTER WHAT HE DID
WITH JERUSALEM.
>> Kimberly: PRESIDENT TRUMP
ADDRESS THE STRATEGIC GOAL OF
THE U.S., DESTROYING ISIS.
>> WE HAVE DEALT ISIS ONE
DEVASTATING DEFEAT AFTER
ANOTHER.
THE CORRELATION TO DEFEAT ISIS
HAS NEVER RECAPTURED ALMOST 100%
OF THE LAND ONCE HELD BY THESE
TERRORISTS IN IRAQ AND SYRIA.
GREAT JOB.
WE ARE NOW CHASING THEM WHEREVER
THEY FLEE AND WE WILL NOT LET
THEM INTO THE UNITED STATES.
>> Kimberly: FOCUS ON NATIONAL
EARLIER ABOUT FORMER PRESIDENTS,
A REAGAN-ESQUE THEME.
HERE USING A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE,
ISIS.
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU CAN DO IS
SHRINK ISIS'S TERRITORY.
PREVENT THEM FROM GETTING HERE
BUT WE HAVE SHOWN IN THE LAST
RADICALIZATION.
ISIS IS ABLE TO PUT VIDEOS
ONLINE TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO USE THE TOOLS WE HAVE
BEEN ORDERED TO PREVENT THAT
FROM HAPPENING.
HE DOESN'T SPELL IT ALL OUT AND
A LOT HAS TO BE CLASSIFIED.
BUT I THINK HE WILL HAVE TO HAVE
A STRONG PUSH, PROBABLY IN THE
STATE OF THE UNION, THAT
MILITARY READINESS WHICH
INCLUDES DEALING WITH THE
LIKE CYBER ATTACKS.
YOU HAD SOMEBODY LIKE CHINA, TO
PULL THIS TOGETHER, WHAT JUAN
WAS TALKING ABOUT.
THIS MORNING CHINA RELEASED A
HUGE PLAN FOR ITS GOVERNMENT TO
BE NUMBER ONE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE GREATER AND
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPER IN THE
WORLD.
THEY ARE WAY AHEAD IN TERMS OF
THAT TYPE OF PLANNING.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE PLAYING
SECOND FIDDLE TO THAT.
I THINK NEXT YEAR, YOU SET THE
STAGE FOR HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES TO THE
MILITARY AND INTELLIGENCE FORCES
>> Jesse: THOSE RESOURCES,
MILITARY.
TO JUAN'S POINT, HE HAS RIPPED
CALIPHATE.
NO ARTIFICIAL TIMELINES IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THE IRAN REVOLUTIONARY GUARD IS
LABELED AS A TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION.
THAT DEAL IS IN THE CROSS HAIRS.
AND THE NORTH KOREA SITUATION,
MAJOR SANCTIONS SLAPPED ON THEM.
TO SAY THAT THE PRESIDENT ISN'T
REALLY DOING ANYTHING OR HASN'T
SPELLED OUT HOW HE'S DOING IT,
OF LEATHER OUT THERE.
>> Greg: I CAN'T REMEMBER
THEY WERE INTERVIEWING AN EXPERT
AND HE WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW
TRUMP HAD A BAD YEAR.
TRUMP HAD A BAD YEAR EXCEPT FOR
ISIS.
EXCEPT FOR ISIS, THE ECONOMY IS
DOING PRETTY GOOD.
BUT HE HAD A REALLY BAD YEAR.
YEAH, EXCEPT FOR ISIS.
IF ALL HE DID WAS ISIS, THAT'S
DON'T KNOW HOW TRUE IT IS BUT
WHAT A DIFFERENCE FROM OBAMA WHO
GAVE A PASS TO HEZBOLLAH.
I'M NOT SURE IF THAT'S TRUE BUT
IT'S SOMETHING MAYBE WE SHOULD
PICK UP A COPY OF A NEWSPAPER
AND IT IT WOULD SAY OH, MY GOSH.
TERROR ALL ALONG.
IT IS SO OFFENSIVE.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHAT YOU SAY.
>> Greg: WAS IT IN "POLITICO"?